-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-Thank you very much.
Okay. Thank you. Love you, too.
Thank you.
I know why you're happy.
Halloween is over, I...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I know it's fun,
but it's just...
just exhaust-- The kids.
-Fucking kids, you know.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I do the same thing every year.
I dress up as a priest
and then they just run away.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
But, uh, oh, I kid the catholic.
But yes,
it's also the time of year
where we set our clocks back.
This week, yeah.
And after electing, uh,
Mike Johnson as speaker,
this is twice in one week
for the Republicans.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Have you seen this guy? Ooh.
Super, uh... (CHUCKLES)
I mean, there's Christy,
and then there's Christy,
this Mike--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-This... this...
this Mike Johnson guy.
And, listen to this.
This is just weird,
out of left field,
we found out about him this week
'cause we don't know this guy.
-Uh, has no bank account.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I'm not making it u--
They cannot find any tra--
No bank account,
no savings account,
-no stu-- What is he, a pimp?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
'Cause...
No-- (CHUCKLES)
Who in this-- What is he--
(HESITATES) That's what we need,
a Speaker of the House
who's off the grid.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-That's-- Gives me
a lot of confidence.
So, the first thing
he wants to do is, uh, you know,
we voted all this money
to beef up the IRS,
which we need,
because of a lot of tax cheats.
He wants to take
some of that money away.
Fourteen billion dollars,
take that away,
which they did the score
and they found
it actually adds to the du--
to the debt.
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
So, you see, Mike,
this is what happens
when you use
only Christian accountants.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Um. Oh, yeah.
Speaking of that,
the FBI Director,
Christopher Wray, he testified
at the Senate panel
on anti-Semitism.
It is at historic levels.
The threat level, they say,
has gone from Mel Gibson
to Kanye.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-So, uh...
No, it's, uh,
it's... it's not funny,
and especially
in a city like this.
We have a lot of Jewish people.
Couple here today, I hope.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLES) Yeah, all right.
But we see it.
I mean, Canter's Deli,
it's right down the street here.
You saw this get vandalized.
People wrote on it, things like,
"Israel's only religion
is capitalism."
And "How many dead
in the name of greed,"
they wrote. Of course, that one
was just about the pastrami.
-But, um...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
(BILL CHUCKLES)
Oh, we make little jokes.
But, yes, uh, the ground war
has now started
in the Middle East, in Gaza.
The Israeli troops are going
building by building,
hoping to root out
Hamas-supporting radicals.
And if it works there,
they're gonna try it at Cornell.